[Musique]
ce village plumaugat dans les codes du
nord fait partie de ce qu'on appelle ici
la zone la zone ce sont 62 communes
comme celle ci mis en quarantaine
quadrillé par la troupe et les gendarmes
la fièvre aphteuse s'est installée rien
à plumaugat en a dénombré 16 foyers et
elle a vidé les rues elle a bouleversé
la vie des habitants des agriculteurs
dont certains ont tout perdu
provoqué l'abattage systématique de
centaines d'animaux par ferme
c'est un désastre pour la région ceux
qui sont épargnés par ce fléau s'enferme
chez eux ils craignent qu'un parent un
voisin transmettent le virus en le
désinfectant pas la semelle de ses
chaussures ou les pneus de sa voiture
ayant pénétrer dans les terres tous les
rassemblements sont interdits les
rencontres sportives annulées
les cinémas fermés et même l'église est
touchée à plumaugat il n'y a plus deux
mais ce vide est partout dans la région
s'amoncellent les cadavres d'animaux
abattus des hommes de troupe sont
chargés le plus souvent de cette besogne
et creuse à la hâte des fausses comme
celle ci où les animaux tués sont
ensevelis sous de la chaux
[Musique]